[Music]
hello there you are watching The Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making headlines with Sonia
soda the chief leader writer of The
Observer and Matt Nathan home Affairs
editor for the times they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's take a look at some of those front
pages now we'll start with the front
page of the eye sunax crisis cabinet is
how the I describe prime minister
Richard sunac's new team which of course
he announced earlier today the financial
times also quotes Mr sunak's words from
here in Downing street that the country
is now confronting what he calls a
profound crisis
this is the Daily Express which reports
how Mr sunak has vowed to fix the
mistakes he says were made under this
trust
that promise made in his first down
issued address is also the lead for the
Daily Telegraph
the times two makes that pledge its
front page lead
the guardian calls today's reshuffle a
gamble restoring experienced hands to
Cabinet including swella bravman just
days after she was forced to resign for
breaching the ministerial code
the Metro pictures Mr sunac at the
palace before he went on to number 10
with the headline Kings can only get
better as an echo Labor's Mantra from
the days of Tony Blair
the same picture on the front of the
male with Mr sunac apparently telling it
King Charles leave it to me Your Majesty
with all the ins and outs the star
Likens the cabinet reshuffled to the
okikoki with Mr sunac shaking it all
about while the sun imagines the new PM
talking talari the Downing Street can
telling him at least I got rid of the
other MOG that's Jacob Reese MOG of
course you know that and a reminder that
by scanning the QR code that you see on
your screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
papers while you watch along with us
well as I said we're joined tonight by
Sonia Soda Chief leader writer at The
Observer and Matt dathan home Affairs
editor at the Times Sonia Matt lovely to
have you with us on another amazing day
in British politics Let's uh dive
straight in and we'll start with I think
the front page of the I newspaper uh
there that um of course lays out that
this is a new cabinet but as they're
describing a crisis cabinet
that's right I think when you look at
what's in Michigan
it's quite daunting really of course A
lot of it is of his predecessors making
so Liz truss came in was prime minister
for sort of 48 days did her mini budget
which included tens of billions of
unfunded unfunded tax cuts lots of
people wander if you do this you're
going to have a huge impact on the
markets that's what's happened and so
that's made Rishi sunak's job coming in
a lot more difficult he's now what he's
done today is kind of as some people
predicted he's tried to construct a
cabinet that brings together all wings
of the conservative party he's sort of a
leader now of a very fractious party
where a lot of conservative MPS are very
worried about losing their seats but I
think there were some interesting and
quite worrying picks in there actually
in particular I'm thinking about Zoella
braveman I'm sure we're going to come on
to talk about that but somebody who had
to resign after you know just six days
ago essentially because she broke the
ministerial code and compromised
security as Home Secretary Gavin
Williamson also is back he during his
tenure as education sector she was I
think one of the most incompetent
education secretaries this country's
ever seen so I'm definitely some eyebrow
raising choices in there we don't think
it was a defense as well for a while
didn't go very well there either did it
that's true that is true so I mean
yesterday we're talking about this being
a government of all the talons go I mean
is that how you see it as well uh Matt
it's certainly a cabinet of all the
across the political spectrum of the
conservative party that's for sure and
it's ironic isn't it that uh the
youngest prime minister of in the modern
in modern times is is appointed a
cabinet full of old hands you know the
likes of Michael Gove Mel stride
um the guy Williamson although he he's
obviously had controversy he's been
there before but he's also kept James
cleverley a big trust Ally and also
supporter of Boris Johnson so he's
obviously trying to reach out and what's
really interesting is um there's five
former Chief whips in there as well
which I think is an eye on party
discipline yeah
exactly and it's spider we think would
be there too as well let's look at the
front page of the express now their uh
headline undaunted Rishi vows to fix
mistakes it was fascinating because Liz
trusses speak to his quick Unapologetic
and she was off but I wish you soon I
came here very clear said twice within
about five seconds of each other there
were mistakes made and I'm here to fix
it absolutely and what was really
um I guess quite refreshing and a change
of tone was when he came up here he took
his time Denise he sort of took the
atmosphere and all the cameras were on
him and everything and he he was very
honest he said we are living in the
profound times and there'll be difficult
decisions to be made but he said you
know I'm here to give you the economic
stability and just like his message to
the conservative party yesterday when he
said unite or die he's basically saying
it's the country there'll be difficult
decisions to be made but I'm the I'm the
man to to bring that stability yeah
let's bring up the telegraph front page
as well because that was just the moment
the pitch they used on the front page
there so in just a moment just as he
goes in and it was telling that there
was no smile a couple of waves but he
was very serious very somber I mean do
you think that's reflective of the way
that you want to change the tone change
the way that the party's been running
well I guess it's quite a different
style from Boris Johnson isn't it and
really listen Trust
thing is you is hit the Helm of you know
the country whoever's in number 10
Downing Street the economic fundamentals
haven't changed we started off in quite
a grim position this year with Energy
prices going up because of the war in
Ukraine brexit having an impact on
exports and it's been made a lot worse
as I was just saying with Liz truss and
her mini budget so I think Rishi sunak
he didn't have much choice but to stand
there and say we made some mistakes
almost well actually what he really said
was mistakes have been made things have
been got wrong very very uh point to use
of the passive tensor but I mean if he
hadn't said that I mean it would have
just been ludicrous really because
everyone can see the huge mistakes that
this trust made so I think he basically
had to come out and say that I think I
mean to be honest I think it's just
going to get harder and harder from him
from here because he's got to make you
know we've been hearing from Jeremy Hunt
who stayed in the treasury and Rishi
sunax dropped hints they think they're
going to be inflicting some very very
painful spending cuts on the country now
what does that mean that means the NHS
that's already on its knees isn't going
to get the funding settlement it needs
it means that schools are going to be
more hard done by I think it means you
know low-paid parents who get tax
credits they might not see their tax
credits go up by the full amount of
inflation we'll have to you know see
what happens there but it's going to be
very difficult to get some of those
measures through the conservative back
benches the only saving grace for them
is that no conservative MP wants a
general election right now so there's
this question of will they just fall
into line and do this very very
unpopular stuff but it's going to cause
a lot of hardship happening there
definitely is any idea at this point
where the accident is going to fall
because they've both made it very clear
haven't they in every chance they've got
to speak that there are going to be some
painful choices to come but no
indication yet where that pain is going
to be no and there's some indication
actually tonight with the reappointment
of Ben Wallace but also Johnny Mercer as
veterans Minister attending cabinet that
if he's if he's really going to push
ahead is he going to push ahead with
three percent of GDP on defense because
that has to be paid for exactly yeah and
and that was we were hearing earmarked
you know for for the chop with um Jeremy
Hunt on Monday and the times are
reporting tomorrow that um he's even
considering pushing back Monday's fiscal
statement to give him a bit more time
because of so many agonizing choices in
the I mean we might also go for tax
Rises he's been unafraid of doing that
before hasn't he well I did actually ask
that question yesterday whether or not
that National Insurance right that he of
course brought in to fund the NHS could
find its way back in some cases I mean
very difficult for a new Tory prime
minister to come in and raise taxes
again wouldn't that yeah but I think
that might be those might be the sorts
of measures that we're looking at
because at the end of the day there is
this sort of black hole in the numbers
and it's been made a lot worse Again by
the by the mini budget that sort of you
know made the created that sort of very
negative Market reaction so um I think
it's going to be very very difficult
actually I mean let's face it when we're
talking about public services schools
hospitals like there just isn't any
money to cut because we've had 12 years
essentially of underfunding for the NHS
and public real public spending cuts in
areas like schools and education and so
you know there isn't
I think a lot of conservative ministers
when they like to talk about it they
like to sort of give it the name
efficiency savings I'm not sure that
there are any efficiencies to be found
really when you've got head teachers
saying well you know it's literally a
choice now for us do we turn the heating
down or do we lay off some of our staff
so take a look at the front page of the
financial times which called leads us
out described as the profound crisis I
mean it's really sort of putting in
really in quite Stark terms isn't it um
but it is to be said that the markets
have been a bit pecans since Jeremy Hunt
came in and we've seen the pound against
the dollar there is one of its highest
points I remember it being for a couple
of weeks now yeah although I hear that I
was reading earlier that that's slightly
more to do with the housing market in
the US or slowing down but the cost of
borrowing has gone down since sunak
became prime minister which is uh good
good news to the same sort of level as
before list trust came in so yeah the
cost of this trust is slowly coming down
isn't it yeah although I do think that
some of that is in anticipation of the
public spending cuts that they expect
wish you see Mac and Jeremy Hunt to make
yeah it will be fascinating to see if
that many next fiscal plans that what
they're calling it midterm fiscal plan
it's a budget whether it gets pushed
back we'll find I guess in a couple of
days time right Sonia Matt thank you
very much for that now still to come
we'll have more reporting on Rishi sunax
appointment of Dominic Robbins Deputy
Prime Minister The Daily Star scathingly
reads the man with no brains returns
thank you
hello and welcome back you are watching
The Press preview with our guests
tonight Sonia Soda Chief leader writer
at The Observer and Matt's Dayton home
Affairs edia editor for the times it's
on your mat let's take a look at the
front page of the Guardian now this is a
picture that's on many of the front
pages uh Richie sunac meeting King
Charles and I thought from you on on
that on that picture because of course
it reminds many of us of that moment
when this trust met uh Lake Manchester
absolutely and this is
a very very a long time but it does seem
like I mean it was only six weeks ago
obviously that there's trust and we were
we were out here doing all of this again
um but yeah he will be doing weekly
audiences with King Charles King Charles
obviously didn't have very many with
less trust because she just wasn't
around long enough for them
um but yeah it says you know it's a sort
of New Era that we're in when it comes
to the person who's at the other side of
the audience really and we should see
now obviously have to get to know this
man and it's going to be a very
interesting relationship between the two
men I guess yeah I wish I was a fly on
the wall in just one of those many
meetings that they have um 37 minutes
today and I don't know what they would
have been talking about but yeah haven't
they yeah absolutely yeah it's
fascinating of course this will be
Prince Charles's first chance to kind of
not get too involved in politics which
he said he wanted he wanted not of
course being criticized for over the
years sort of being too political and
not kind of keeping that Royal
impartiality and I think sometimes on
some issues it's worked quite well like
with the environment you know he he was
a massive campaigner on the climate
crisis before lots of other people were
but then there are other sort of courses
close to its heart like Homeopathy which
uh may be slightly more questionable I'm
sure they won't be talking about that
would be interesting to see if he gets
reinvited to cop27 because I think this
trust is sweated him from government so
that will be yeah
obviously big changes there with alok
Sharma as well kind of being moved out
of that role so all right let's take a
look at the Daily Star now just for for
fun because it's always a good for a
laugher and they're describing what's
been happening with that cabinet
reshuffle as the Hokey Cokey song I like
to sing with my my little boy every now
and again and there have been some ins
and outs haven't there yeah absolutely
it's comparing uh Dominic Raab to a
brain to know no brains
even though they've got a picture of a
brain and that refers to Dominic Robb in
the middle of party Gates uh last
November he was just as secretary then
and he's returned to that job and he
famously said that police don't
investigate crimes a year ago referring
to why they shouldn't investigate the
party Gates that's why that's that's the
reference there but no it is the bit of
a hokikoki because he's cleared out 10
ministers today and brought in many old
people yeah